merci d'être là merci d'y croire encore
moi je crois l'avenir de la droite je le
crois d'ailleurs à l'avenir que de la
droite pour notre pays redynamiser la
droite dans les Yvelines et au niveau
national c'est la priorité d'Othman
Nasro le vice-président de la Région
Île-de-France et premier secrétaire
général délégués des républicains se
présente pour la présidence à la
Fédération yvelinoise DLR son premier
souhait que le parti regagne du terrain
dans le département nous allons avoir
des élections sénatoriales et il est
extrêmement important dans ces élections
que l'on donne la majorité la plus large
possible et bien à nos sénateurs et au
président du Sénat parce que le Sénat
est aujourd'hui un pôle de stabilité
majeur quand on voit l'état de
l'Assemblée nationale que deuxième
objectif rajeunir le parti et faire
émerger des talents
otman Nasro a déjà fait appel à de
nouveaux membres dans son équipe
aujourd'hui le parti est vieillissant et
je pense que c'est sa jeunesse les
nouvelles méthodes en fait qu'il faut
utiliser pour redynamiser le parti
et faire un renouveau dans cette salle
de la selle Saint-Cloud ils étaient plus
de 80 militants à venir soutenir le
candidat je connais déjà Hotmail c'est
quelqu'un de merveilleux qui a le sens
du travail qui est effectivement dans
les Yvelines je peux vous dire qu'il va
se battre on aura beaucoup de monde
derrière lui d'ailleurs il est très
charismatique très apprécié et beaucoup
de jeunes maintenant viennent auprès de
lui je sais que c'est quelqu'un de
brillant d'intelligent et qui va pouvoir
insuffler un nouveau souffle à notre
fédération pour le moment aucun autre
candidat n'est connu pour cette élection
ce scrutin interne devrait se tenir
cours en novembre